little na's x seemingly has beef with
tony hawk and the whole thing has three
little words going viral nah he tweaking
that's life let me get you up to speed
the whole thing started when the pro
skateboarder released his collab with
beverage company liquid death that
featured a skateboard deck that was
painted using tony's actual blood the
limited edition boards have since sold
out but on wednesday lil na's ex pointed
out the similarities between tony's
recent launch and the musician's
previously released nike air max 97
satan shoes which featured a drop of
human blood the grammy winner tweeted
wednesday quote now that tony hawk has
released skateboards with his blood
painted on them and there was no public
outrage are y'all ready to admit y'all
were never actually upset over the blood
in the shoes and maybe you were mad for
some other reason yeah
back in march the montero call me by
your name singer's controversial shoe
sparked some online backlash and nike
later sued mischief the brooklyn-based
streetwear company lil na's x teamed up
with to create the shoe but the two
parties later settled the legal battle
when mischief agreed to a voluntary
recall of the limited edition sneakers
and little nasex poked fun at all that
in his music video for industry baby
which dropped in july ladies and
gentlemen
of the jury
this is about much more than shoes
mr nazex
are you gay
what does this have to do with the shoes
answer the question
rephrase the question
do your mama know you gay
yes
yeah lock them up throw away the key
order order order in the court slash
forward to wednesday not only did the
rapper tweet his sentiments about tony's
blood-infused boards when rap tv posted
the news about the skateboarders
launched to instagram and asked y'all
rockin with it lil nasdaq slid into the
comments and bluntly responded nah he
tweaking and thus a meme was born the
comment has over 124 000 likes so far
and inspired tons of people to start
commenting on other popular instagram
posts including some of tony's recent
posts with the now viral phrase nah he
tweak in neither tony nor lil nazex have
directly responded to the viral trend
but in a tweet on wednesday instagram
yes instagram acknowledged the trend
posting this gif and writing quote yeah
we tweak it but only a little bit we're
aware that some people are having issues
loading their comments we're fixing that
and that some are seeing a bunch of
comments saying nah he tweakin what is
that more soon